okay it's the time of the show where we
have to talk about coronavirus
especially after this completely insane
weekend of new cases that we've had
because the United States has quietly
slowly during early-to-mid and now into
late June we have had a period where we
surpassed the worst days from April in
terms of new cases of coronavirus each
day we hit a single day new case record
of more than 47,000 cases on Friday
followed it up with another 43,000 cases
on Saturday another 40,000 cases on
Sunday so the pandemic is worse than
ever what we believed was the peak
nationally in late April has been blown
out of the water by the new case numbers
of late now as a reminder the right
loves to say we have so many cases
because we're doing so much testing this
isn't really a concern we're doing more
tests so we're finding more cases
everything is fine this is not true and
as you can see if you're looking at the
graph that we're putting up on the
screen right now the percentage of
positive tests is going up that's the
blue line one of the things you look for
to see if more cases are merely because
of more tests is you look at whether the
percent of people that test positive
goes up down or stays even as you do
more testing and at the national level
the positive test rate has gone from
about four percent in early to mid June
to about seven percent now okay that's a
75% increase in the positive test rate
nationally that is insane
for comparison some of the states that
are doing okay so far Massachusetts
Connecticut others the positive test
rate is sometimes under 1% or between 1
and 2% when you do much more testing you
would want or expect that positive test
rate to stay even or go down if you are
managing the pandemic well if as you do
more testing the positive test rate
keeps going up it's very very bad and
exactly what's going on in the United
States right now now we're going to talk
about states that are doing well in
states that are doing less well I'm in
Martha's Vineyard in Massachusetts right
now why am I here well the advice is the
safe thing to do as states reopen is to
do in state trips that require driving
but not flying and of course to wear a
mask and all of that stuff Martha's
Vineyard is one of the parts of
Massachusetts that has been less hit by
the virus and when you walk around you
can tell why other other quite frankly
other than tourists from other states
everybody's wearing a mask
there are outdoor pedestrian areas that
are outdoor mask zones there are
restaurants open for outdoor dining
you've got to have your masks on up
until the moment that you sit
everybody's doing it every employee has
a mask you can tell why the numbers are
what they are on the other hand we've
seen a complete unflattering of the
curve thanks to some of the recent worst
offenders and those are as of right now
Arizona the Carolinas North and South
Florida Arkansas and Alabama Mississippi
and Louisiana Utah Texas Nevada Georgia
Iowa California and Tennessee shockingly
the absolutely useless toxic Republican
governor Greg Abbott admits he would not
have opened bars so quickly knowing what
he knows now now this is like such a
minor concession the way you know the
the the real the reality of Texas is
they should have stopped all reopening
and delayed it by several weeks and
actually taken this more seriously
during the closing just getting any any
admission from him any concession is
important he says well I would have
reopened the bars a little more slowly
in his mind opening the stores and the
restaurants you know it was all fine he
just would have maybe opened bars a
little more slowly but again this is a
vile toxic guy his own lieutenant
general lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
is the one who said I would sacrifice
myself and many grandparents also would
for the economy and for their kids or
whatever
so you and I know that what Greg Abbott
is admitting here is BS the fact that
he's admitting anything though is a sign
of just how bad things were going down
in Texas Houston area I see use in at or
near 100% we don't really know because
one hospital hit a hundred percent ICU
capacity then just stopped reporting
numbers altogether so we don't even know
the full story of how bad things are
getting in Texas consider that a bunch
of states decided they had to close
months ago when they had 1/10 the cases
that these states have now understand
the insanity of that when they had
ninety percent fewer cases than they
have now they said we've got to close
now with 10 times the cases they're
saying we have to be open it's a recipe
for absolute and total disaster and
indeed we are all going to pay the price
for it certainly living in certain
states puts you at a lower risk for the
virus but the entire country is being
collectively punished for example Europe
indeed will not allow Americans to come
in as they are now just days from
starting to open up to travel from other
countries we are up there with Brazil
and India and Russia and a bunch of
other places that have not handled this
well meanwhile you're seeing anti-mask
Patriot after anti-mask Patriot
appearing on social media loudly
proclaiming they will not wear masks
well that's why things are so bad
especially in certain parts of the
country and just as a reminder Donald
Trump continues to say we have the best
testing and we have the most testing we
are 26th in testing per capita in the
world right now 26th not first not v not
10th or 15th
we are 26th right now